may I ask you some advice um sure you
encourage and support your daughter to
be herself and have flare absolutely
100% how old did she have to turn in
order for you to fully let her
go well cuz it's different some kids are
more mature uh some parents are
different it's all styles there's no
right or wrong answer everything that
you do is your choice and your style and
what works for you and your family so
how did you do it well it's it's been a
process probably Junior High wanted to
change her hair color all the things I I
just want her to live her most
spectacular life
so how do you know like you know you may
be afraid I I work from a lot you ever
know the right answer period ever so how
even after you make it you don't know
how do you be brave you just do it
that's what bravery is right it's not
knowing and doing it anyway